it is time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a safe and good home how you doing lori
i'm good
uh oh our connection is not a great one
so let me while we're waiting for this
connection to get better let me just
tell you who this is this is
miracle she's holding miracle right
there and miracle needs a good home and
of course
as always you can go to the website
check things out set up an appointment
do a virtual visit with your family
get to know miracle a little bit or any
pet that needs adoption
let's see how our connection is now how
you doing there
oh now lori it's still a little off
the joys of the joys
of zoom or whatever we're using skype
okay all right lori sorry about that
we're just gonna
we're gonna move on but hopefully
someone sees miracle hold up miracle one
more time so we can see him
or her miracle is beautiful so miracle
is looking for a good home
if you want to help miracle and we were
hoping for a miracle with our connection
there didn't happen but you can be the
miracle by calling this phone number
702-873-7722 or go to nevadaspca.org
to learn more about how you can make a
forever home
for one of the pets there